[Music]
it's 1991 and the world is introduced to
a new TV show it's about two brothers
with the same name Pete and Pete was an
absurdist surreal show shot in a very
ordinary looking suburb in New Jersey
we're here in the sight of the old Pete
and Pete house from season two I'm
Michael Moroni and I play big Pete and
I'm Danny Tim really and I play little
Pete we haven't been here in 20 plus yes
and it's it's kind of a time machine
this typical New Jersey house was the
backdrop for the adventures of the
eccentric Wrigley family petunia was my
beloved tattoo fancy knows how I got it
at age seven and I believe only did the
shorts it was on this arm and then at
some point it switched to this arm I had
to start showering with saran wrap on my
arm during the week because they didn't
wanna have to keep touching it up and
making it better so I had a stinky right
arm for three season one of the more
bizarre parts of the show was Artie a
reoccurring character who served as a
constant reminder to viewers that you
can't always ask for an explanation
I believe that Artie was a figment of
our imaginations but he was a hell of a
hallucination because even the adults
believed that he was there Artie is of
course the strongest man he moved the
foundation of our house an inch to the
left
he ran very fast he's eaten several
origami stars that were headed for his
head I mean who wouldn't want to have a
personal superhero with them at all
times as your best friend I would I had
it we are not brothers biologically we
are fake TV brothers food poisoning
that's a triple UE unusual unpredictable
undetectable I didn't hang out with Dan
much in the years immediately following
Pete and Pete we are we are brothers in
a in a weird way spiritual we have a
spiritual bond would you
Podcast together that's an important dan
and I record a podcast called The
Adventures of Danny and Mike so we see
each other quite often and boy are we
still fake TV brothers
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]